починаємо брифінг п'ятого президента
України лідера європейської солідарності
Петра Порошенка та народного
депутата дорогі друзі Відповідно до
Конституції 15 вересня уряд має передати
проект бюджету до Верховної Ради і
конституційним повноваженнями Верховної
Ради є затвердження бюджету наш
сьогоднішній брифінг призначений і хоч
окремо це підкреслити не бюджету Ми з
наступного тижня готові Будемо
запропонувати уряду запропонувати
суспільство наше бачення щодо
надзвичайного бюджету воєнного часу і
які кроки в співпраці з нашим
міжнародними партнерами на нашу думку
будуть максимально ефективні Разом з тим
Ми хочемо підкреслити що розбудову і
фінансування оборонних спроможності і
Збройних Сил України є
найважливішим фактором фактором
виживання фактором Перемоги фактором
існування нашої держави і з цього
приводу у нас є сьогодні дві столові
вимоги по законопроектам які будуть
виноситися цього тижня і стосуватися
акцизів
позиція перша і ми не допустимо щоб вона
пройшла в залі те що запропонувала Влада
щоб вони однією рукою нібито надавали
кошти збройним силам України а другою
цієї же самої кошти вони би
перераховували в дорожній фонд І дальше
спрямовували на Дорожнє будівництво ми
не дозволимо це робити ми не дозволимо
обирати армію ми не дозволимо
маніпулювати з вилученням коштів
збройних сил передавати
дорожньому будівництво Тим більше що
зараз вони ці дороги будують в 10 км або
від кордону або від лінії фронту і
просто прокладають дорогу для можливого
наступна наступу російських збройних сил
дуже наша пропозиція Ми не дамо
проголосувати закон про акцизи якщо
звідти не буде вилучена норма про
обкладання акцизом палівно-мастильних
матеріалів які йдуть на потреби збройних
сил України
зроблять їх без акцизними і де-факто не
будуть зменшувати
фінансування збройних сил ми знайшли
порозуміння в більшості парламентських
фракцій хочу попередньо сказати що
презентували Це в тому числі
імунобільшості і дуже розраховуємо що
найближчим часом ця безглузда ганебна
норма закону який був прийнятий в
першому читанні буде знято А всі кошти
збройних сил України залишаться
недоторканими збройні сили України
паливо будуть отримувати без акцизу і це
наша принципова позиція
друга позиція - це аграрний сектор і
фермери там ситуація не настільки
безапеляційна але ми наголошуємо що
зниження ставки акцизу для
аграріїв український аграрії Зараз
опинилися в надзвичайно важкому стані і
це не тільки тому що
левова частина їх угоді їх посівів була
захоплена ворогам або спалена ворогом ще
й в зв'язку з блокадою де-факто портів
створена
бутылкове горлышко яке обмежує
логістичні можливості експорту для
українських аграріїв що знижує ціни на
їх продукцію і підвищені ціни на
міндобриво підвищення ціни на засоби
захисту рослин підвищені ціни на
паливно-мастильні матеріали сьогодні вже
спонукають фермерів казати що вони не
вийдуть в пори в поле навіть приймати
урожай а вже не кажучи про те щоби сіяти
наступний врожай Ми також вимагаємо
проаналізувати досвід країн
Європейського Союзу де чітко наголошено
що з 28 країн Європейського Союзу був до
19 з них застосовують норми зниженого
акцизу для сільгоспвиробників Скажіть
будь ласка наше сільгоспвиробники вони
що багатше чи більш привільованих в
умовах знаходяться по відношенню до
європейських А конкуруємо ми з ними на
тій ринках І про яку інвестиційну
привабливість говориться на сьогоднішній
день якщо вже навіть вже зараз ми
сьогодні обмежуємо і робимо на
конкурентоздатними українських аграріїв
тут ми готові до компромісів ми готові
шукати порозуміння і ми дуже розуміємо
що наш голос голос українських аграріїв
також буде почути бо це мільйони дітей
які на сьогоднішній день опинилися в
важкому стані в українському селі і
Третє це вже напрямок використання
коштів дорожнього фонду які буде
стягнуто з української економіки і
спрямовано дорожній фон для так званого
Великого будівництва ми твердо
переконані що це надзвичайно ризикований
проект з великими корупційними ризиками
і це не просто що застосовується
корупція А якщо будуть наведені те що
відбувалося до 24 лютого це несе в собі
загрозу що наше партнери просто
припинять надавати кошти гранти позички
в корупційна небезпечну сферу але
Спілкуючись з великими асоціаціями
асоціює європейською
бізнесоціацією і нашим американськими
партнерами і українськими асоціаціями
представників бізнесу ми вважаємо що
якщо ви вже збираєте кошти на дорожній
фонд вони безумовно більше половини з
них негайно має бути спрямована на
розширення е-е пропускних можливостей
західного кордону України Отже треба не
будувати
дороги які вже танками росіян черговий
раз знищена Ми Точно зможемо це зробити
після нашої Перемоги які я сподіваюся
буде незабаром ми підстав для оптимізму
дають перше підсумки контрнаступу А
зараз навіть якщо ви акцизи направляєте
в дорожній фонд на кожному пункті
пропуску на західному кордоні України в
Польщі в Румунії в Словаччині скрізь ми
значно врази збільшуємо пропускну
можливості цих пунктів Ми зробимо більше
е-е можливості і колон для того щоби
скоротити багато десятків кілометрових
черги з вантажівок які сьогодні
заблоковують експорт України і для того
щоб максимальний термін обслуговування
е-е вантажівки вимірювався буквально
декількома хвилинами ті інвестиції які
на сьогоднішній день з дорожнього фонду
підуть на розширення це те що підтримує
народ України підприємців України
експортери України і це треба буде
зробити і одночасно Ми хотіли би
звернутися до представників наших
партнерів з Європейського Союзу щоби за
рахунок коштів Європейського союзу з
боку наших
країн-партнерів-членів Європейського
Союзу були зроблені аналогічні
логістичні можливості для прискорення
перетину кордону
забастовки польських водіїв напружена
ситуація на інших кордонах включно з
Румунією словач твердо дає нам підстави
вважати що це питання буде вирішено вже
протягом днів якщо не тиждень і в цій
ситуації ці кошти ми відповідний
законопроект зареєстрували за нашим
дорученням він вже переданий Я знаю що
він також підтримується і представниками
і в мене більшості і в уряді і ми дуже
сподіваємося що на цьому тижні
пропозиції мої пропозиції нашої
політичної сили і нашої фракції будуть
точно враховані в остаточному варіанті
законів інакше ми точно будемо блокувати
ці абсолютно шкідливі і небезпечні
законопроекти
Я хотіла би додати що все-таки
пропозиції Уряду про повернення акцизів
вони не мають певного обґрунтування не
мають певного послідовного періоду
перехідного періоду від військового часу
на час відновлення економіки і тому Ця
пропозиція викликала таке обурення тому
що після того як всі види пального були
звільнені від оподаткування акцизу
відразу пропонується те що неприйнятно
суспільство це і викликало стільки
запитань особливо те що стосується
збройних сил України тому абсолютно
очевидно що механізми контролю для того
щоб збройні сили України отримували без
акцизу пальне є вони прописані в
Податковому кодексі Я думаю що
при хорошому адмініструванні ніяких
пересікань зловживань не буде І
правильно в любому випадку
ми маємо І сьогодні і завтра робити все
для того щоб фінансування збройних сил
України і взагалі захисту України
України ні в якому разі не зменшувалося
на які б благи цілі не збиралися нібито
спрямувати ці кошти тому і друга наша
пропозиція про те що якщо вже із
економіки і від людей будете збирати
кошти в дорожній фонд то Давайте тоді
спрямовувати в тому числі на розширення
і в першу чергу мабуть на розширення
можливостей пунктів пропуску
автомобільних які вплинуть на можливості
нашої економіки а збільшення можливостей
ти знову ж збільшення надходжень в
державний бюджет і ці кошти ми знову
направимо на збройні сили України тому
абсолютно реальні раціональні пропозиції
які мають бути бути прийняті в залі і
тоді можуть бути проголосовані такі
законів інакше насправді в нас є всі
можливості
не дати прийняти ці проекти в залі і тим
більше якби зупинити це свавілля яке
розпочинається вже на цьому етапі тому
що якщо говорити про подальші планування
і як ми будемо планувати державне бюджет
на 2023 рік то тут є теж дуже багато
запитань і ми вимагаємо такої ж поваги
до народних депутатів яка конституційної
поваги яка була раніше все має
витрачання з державного бюджету мають
бути прозорі і ми маємо мати повну
інформацію щодо щодо видатків наприклад
з резервного фонду цьогоріч тому що
починаючи з 23 лютого
саме уряд за погодженням з верховним
головнокомандувачем має право визначати
пріоритетні видатки зменшуючи видатки
заплановані по всім розпорядникам і
витрачати їх на ті цілі які для них є
пріоритетними ми від цього процесу всі
відсторонені Тому перед розглядом мабуть
бюджету на 2023 рік нам потрібно
ознайомитися з повною інформацією і
потім далі рухатися усвідомлюючи який ми
плануємо воєнний бюджет на наступний рік
тому всі думаю об'єднаємося в залі
навколо наших пропозицій і в разі
прийняття
цих проектів ми будемо виступати якби
об'єднано і в тому числі
правляча чи більшість чи слуги народу в
залі також будуть підтримувати наші
ініціативи Я ще раз Хочу підкреслити
останні слова Ніни Петрівни тому що мова
йдеться не про Ультиматум мова йдеться
про єдність єдність цього парламенту для
захисту оборонних коштів України мова
йдеться про єдність в кроках які точно
будуть перешкоджати будь-яким
корупційним проявам ризикам де весь
парламент має об'єднатися для захисту
України Це є кредом нашої партії нашої
фракції я твердо переконаний що це
підтримується нашим народом Слава
збройним силам України і слава Україні